eine echte chance kommt mit der korona
krise wir könnten endlich mit der
verkehrswende vorankommen ja und dafür
muss man das rad auch gar nicht neu
erfinden das rad gibt es ja schon ja
weil sich aus angst vor viren immer
weniger leute in busse oder bahnen
setzen erlebt das fahrrad bei uns einen
regelrechten boom
es wird den händlern aus den händen
gerissen vor allem das e-bike jetzt
müsste man die leute nur irgendwie auf
dem sattel halten
andere sind da weiter paris investiert
300 millionen in radwege london macht
jetzt große teile der innenstadt
autofrei
in brüssel gilt seit mai tempo 20 für
autos und fahrräder haben immer vorfahrt
wahnsinn er so weit sind wir in
deutschland leider noch nicht außer in
anschnallen freunde berlin quasi über
nacht sehen popup fahrradwege autospuren
entstanden als normal monate oder jahre
dauert geht auch schneller
wir sind inzwischen in dem tonus eine
woche nach denken und planen und in der
nächsten woche ausführen keine woche
zwischen planung und ausführung in
berlin
den passenden br witz finden sie auf
videotext tafel 706 wenn die leute
dauerhaft beim rat bleiben sollen was
schön wäre muss das mit deutlich weniger
todesangst verbunden sein denn während
die zahl der verkehrstoten bei uns
kontinuierlich sinkt sterben leider von
jahr zu jahr mehr radfahrer ist aber
ohne echte und nur mit aufgemalten
radspuren macht das alles wenig freude
hier dieser man hilft sich selbst eine
ein meter fünfzig poolnudel ich habe
schon mal so eine poolnudel test gemacht
ein bus hat gemeinde müsste mich
überholen mit sicherlich zu wenig
abstand und meine nudeln greta im
wahrsten sinn des wortes unter die räder
das wünscht man wirklich kein weniger
motorisierter individualverkehr ist der
einzige weg zu lebenswerteren in städten
das weiß jeder
seit jahren mehr fahrräder mehr
carsharing und mehr hilfen für den
öffentlichen nahverkehr der ja auch
gerade quasi an corona stirbt wenn wir
nicht aufpassen
es wäre geradezu tragisch wenn nach der
krise alle wieder stumpf einzelnen ihre
einsteigen und der kampf fahrrad gegen
auto nahtlos weitergeht
[Musik]
neben den radfahr wieder denken sie
haben immer vorfahrt
[Applaus]
nix für weicheier
meine prognose der triumphzug des
fahrrads den wir gerade erleben
er hält nicht lange an denn die
konterrevolution die läuft ja links der
adac schäumt wegen der neuen berliner
radwege
da würden und ich zitiere
partikularinteressen vertreten von der
mächtigen fahrradlobby sagt der adac
ohne rot zu werden partikularinteressen
also damit wir uns nicht falsch
verstehen
die haben nichts generell gegen
fahrräder an sich der adac hat jetzt
sogar ein eigenes bike entwickelt
grundgedanke der designer
warum nicht das herkömmliche fahrrad
noch besser machen
zum beispiel die sache mit den
zweirädern es brandgefährlich es gibt so
leicht um so und was ist das schön
scheiß unbequemer sitzt das geht gar
nicht das ist ein sitz und warum
überhaupt noch einer und noch einer
reihe kann endlich eine familie zusammen
gerade und diese blöde treterei das geht
nicht denn er muss da muss ein fetter
diesel rein dann braucht ihr natürlich
noch viel schutz und an der seite damit
man nicht nass wird und zacken
fuchsschwanz hat jetzt kann man damit
auf die straße ohne sich zu schämen ja
so wird ein fahrrad raus
gegen diese leute hast du keine chance
der autofahrer bleibt der bestimmer im
land garantiert bestes beispiel die
debatte über an die chance neuen
bußgeldkatalog wir erinnern uns da stand
ursprünglich mal drin 21 sachen zu
schnell innerorts zack ist der lappen
weg für einen monat ganz kurz dachte man
dann an die steuer macht fast
vernünftiges das schreibe ich mir den
kalender
ja aber dann ein paar tausend wütende
mails von rasern später der
verkehrsminister reagiert nun auf die
beschwerden
er will wieder weg vom
führerscheinverlust politik muss auch
die kraft haben das verständnis
aufzubringen für die bürgerinnen und
bürger die sich bei uns melden und sagen
macht es wieder in den alten stand
zurück
millionen von bürgern melden sich
täglich bei dir und sagen tritt endlich
zurück wegen der maut ist jedoch auch
scheißegal argumentation zum
bußgeldkatalogs 30er schild würde man ja
auch mal übersehen im eifer des gefechts
und dann gleich führerschein weg das
wäre jetzt doch zu hart wo drüber
nachdenkt hier neu bei rtl
der typ dafür viel zu schnell vielleicht
hat er das 30er schild übersehen oder
hat stress im büro oder privat
manchmal zu schnell fahren ja auch
einfach nur ein hilferuf da muss man
auch ein stück weit differenzieren kaum
feiern wir rasen nach hause
der alarm für schauer 11 ab jetzt werden
beide augen zugedrückt
an die scheuer immer noch der beste
freund aller bleifüße dabei behauptet
der mann doch immer er wäre auch unser
fahrrad minister sagte doch ständig
vorschlag laut fahrrad hähnchen macht
doch endlich mal den abbieger
assistenten für lkw zur pflicht in
deutschland immer wieder werden
radfahrer von rechts abbiegenden laster
getötet ja sagt ein deutscher alleingang
sei hier leider nicht möglich wegen
europarecht erstens bei der maut war der
europarecht auch egal
ja zweitens in österreich geht es
komisch in der hauptstadt wien gilt ab
nächstem jahr ein rechtsabbiegen verbot
für alle lkw ohne abbiege assistentin
also ein rechtsabbiegen verbot würde man
sich auch für attila hildmann und xavier
naidoo wünschen fazit verkehrswende
fällt weiter aus aber bringt corona
wenigstens den klimaschutz voran
wir erleben ja gerade den stärksten co2
rückgang seit 60 jahren
leider ist aber auch dass wohl nur eine
momentaufnahme der rebound der fossilen
energien steht schon vor der tür
höchste zeit mit unserer jungen
generation x schonungslos offen zu
sprechen auch wenn es weh tut und mama
und papa müssen wir sorgen mit gürtel
und dem oli
so passen auf linus - jesus kinos wir
machen das hier nicht zu schade heute
wieder so fahrig was ist denn mit dem
jetzt endlich - mama und ich müsse mir
dir über deine zukunft sprechen
wir finden du bist jetzt alt genug für
die wahrheit als wir haben immer noch
keine nachricht von deiner kita ob du
wieder hin darfst und man in deutschland
je wieder eine schule regulären
unterricht gibt weiß auch keine sei also
kurz gesagt der papa und ich wir denken
und bitte fangen jetzt nicht gleich
wieder an zu flennen also wir denken
dass mit einem abitur kannst du
vergessen ja - da muss man auch einmal
realistisch sein
deswegen haben wir und ich deinen
studien vor jetzt einfach mal aufgelöst
ja du wir haben davon segelboot gekauft
ist das nicht vorher so und wo wir
gerade bei unangenehmen wahrheiten sind
junge ihr kinder interessiert euch doch
so wahnsinnig für diesen klimaschutz
ja das wird jetzt wohl auch leider
leider linus leider weil wir haben
nämlich gerade echt erwachsenen probleme
du ein bündnis der energieintensiven
industrien warnt die regierung in einem
brandbrief zu ehrgeizige klimaziele
könnten den wirtschaftlichen neustart
nach kona abwürgen
die drastische verschärfungen des 2030er
ziels auf bis zu 55 prozent war ja schon
vor corona extrem ambitioniert deswegen
sind wir der auffassung dieses ziel muss
jetzt auf den prüfstand ich glaube nicht
nur in deutschland so in europa ist es
dann zeit ein kassensturz zu machen und
sich zu überlegen was sind die
prioritäten jetzt gucken so beleidigt
wenn man großes muss man halt
prioritäten setzen und die rettung der
welt ist jetzt halt erstmal ein
luxusproblem und dass wir uns dann
später kümmern und wenn ich manchmal wir
sagt da mal zu dich linus deine
generation kann für klimaschutz doch
irgendwas erfinden geht ja gar nicht
ohne schulbildung
meine klar klar das ist jetzt blöd für
dich - die mama und ich wir sind einfach
zum perfekten zeitpunkt geboren
zu spät für den krieg aber zu früh für
die klimakatastrophe
wir haben das leben noch genossen aber
hallo bali hawaii übers wochenende nach
barcelona auf gott hatten wir keine zeit
echt wobei der linus sei eigentlich auch
so eine sache noch du bist jetzt schon
total pleite richtig die geschichte - du
hast dich wohl leider bis über beide
ohren verschuldet bisher hat der bund
schon 453 milliarden für corona helfen
verband dazu kommen noch garantien über
mehr als 800 milliarden also wir wollen
jetzt keine angst machen aber es kann
sehr gut sein
dazu dass am ende alles zahlt also
schränkt dich ein bisschen ja diese tüte
chocobos muss bis zum abi reichen
entstehen beziehungsweise
hauptschulabschluss
wir haben uns total verplaudert unser
zug geht gleich stimmt das haben ja gar
nicht erzählt mama und papa fahren übers
wochenende nach sind das geht ja jetzt
aber keine angst die oma passt auf die
augen auf aber nicht umarmen und
mundschutz tragen sonst stirbt die uni
mama und papa müssen die wagen mit
gürtel und im oly
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
nike dallas ich hab die schnauze voll
loslassen abo da